Here are the four answers. Great work if you've had at least two of those. For
the second one you might have written it as negative root 6 or negative 1 times
root 6. Both are correct. For this third one we can't add the radicals together
since the radicants are different. We do have the same index since we have a
square root. But this radicand is a 2 and this one's a 3. So we leave this as
is. Here's a little bit more work to make it more clear. We have 4 root 3 minus
2 root 3. So if I have four of these root 3s and I subtract 2 of these root 3s,
I'm left with two of the root 3s. We see that if we factor out a root 3 from
the first term and the second term. This would live us with the quantity 4
minus 2 time root 3. We simplify the number in front of our radical sign to get
2. Now you don't need to show this step in your problem solving but if it
helps, you can definitely do it. Whenever I add and subtract radicals I just
look at the numbers in front and then look at what I need to do with them.
Should I add or subtract these? In this case I subtract, so I just have 4 minus
2, which is 2 of 3. This last problem was just like one we've seen before. We
want to make sure that we have a 1 in front of this, a cube root of 3. So we're
really subtracting 9 minus 1, which equals 8. We want to make sure that we keep
our root on the end so we have 8 times the cubed root of 3. I hope your getting
the hang of this.